welcome Raf
also co-author on the paper
so how are you
doing uh I'm good what about
you pretty good other than this brief
interval of white light I'm just hanging
out fantastic so I'm trying to figure
out here how I can uh I'm using a
different uh slide sofware so I need to
uh make sure that I can pull this up in
the right way so give me just a quick
second yeah
great cool so just just to um read off
what's coming while you figure that um
out so right now we have RF calman
and this presentation is going to be
Gaia an ACM powered Network for
planetary scale sense making following
this 30-minute presentation we'll have a
GW and Caro on embedded normativity that
looks perfect that's
perfect awesome all right thanks Ral to
you thank you all right I I was gonna
try to see if I could upload this up to
full screen but I I I got it I I got it
on the
Stream
looks good on the stream go for it cool
so I'm just pulling up my notes here all
right so uh let me just test that this
moves did I just move the
slide great cool all right so uh as I
said hi everyone it's a huge pleasure to
be here and thank you so much to Daniel
and everybody else at The Institute for
organizing this I'm going to talk about
what I think is the single most
important application of active inance
not as a detriment to the others but
it's sort of Upstream of everything else
and that is how do the eight billion of
us humans make sense of what's going on
in our planet and all scales and how do
we use that understanding to survive as
a
species so this presentation here is a a
bit of a technical presentation and uh
it has a lot of content it's going to
move pretty fast and assume that you're
familiar with some Concepts but but I'm
going to try to leave time for Q&A at
the end so first of all I'm going to
talk about the motivation behind what
we're doing uh in particular the
concepts of the meta crisis and the
third attractor then I'll give an
overview of our Network architecture and
the application so far and cover the
many remaining challenges and last but
not least I plan to convince you that
this is the single most important thing
you could ever be working on and I'm
doing this because we need your help so
that's a taser of what we have and uh so
as I said let's jump right into it with
the motivation and what greater
motivation could there be um if you
haven't heard of the metac crisis uh
it's a term that it's originally from
Doctor Who but it was Borrowed by uh
thinker called Daniel schenberg to talk
about the total risk for Humanity and
the biosphere that is posed by the
combination of three factors the first
being the increasing interconnectedness
of everything from climate to food
security to National Security to
biodiversity and everything in between
the second being the the risk associated
with self-evolving technology including
runaway artificial intelligence and the
third being the increasing uh Omni
presence of coordination failures
personified as the the god of
coordination failures molok and so the
combination of these three factors as
hypothesized by schenberg will lead to
either one of of two attractors one of
them being chaotic breakdown of uh all
structure and the second being a
reversal to oppressive authoritarian
control and obviously both of those
qualify as bad in my book I assume in
yours as well so the question of course
is can we actually find a third
attractor that is positive sum as
opposed to negative sum and rather the
question is can we design it so what I
claim and what we as the the guy
Consortium claim is that yes we can uh
and we can design this attractor and
it's the design goal is basically to
build resilience and uh uh stabilization
into our biooo economic system and to do
this subject to multi-level system
constraints like the planetary
boundaries uh desirability meaning it
has to be something that people actually
want so they will help it happen uh so
it needs to preserve standards of living
and so on and it needs to be feasible it
needs to be achievable from our current
initial conditions and of course there's
a lot of design complicators in the mix
uh some of which uh partial observation
there's lots of information symmetry
going on uh there's a lot of uncertainty
about how the pieces of the world system
work from a scientific perspective
there's obvious computability
constraints Associated to this and last
but not least uh you can't really
control what happens in most cases we
can only create incentives
recommendations and
nudges
so uh easy right of course it's not easy
but we think we can do it if we apply
the the sum of the principles from
cybernetics that you already know and
apply them in a
decentralized uh positive sum composable
way so uh what we're talking about here
is uh decentralized Network a
decentralized hybrid AI human Network
for plantary scale decision support and
automation uh it features uh it
recognizes that we will have human and
artificial agents interacting by the
billions in an open network it uh its
goal is to facilitate both consilience
or model alignment and coherence or goal
alignment at multiple level or scales up
to the global scale meaning the survival
of the system as a whole uh it will need
to feature builtin incentives and
governance and it will need to be priv
privacy preserving intrinsically so uh
the below listed participants are
participants founders of the of the
Consortium I'm going to talk about it
later but so this is the framing this is
the motivation for what we're doing and
uh and now I'm going to give a whirlwind
tour of the architecture so far and I'm
going to cover mostly what uh we've
built uh the the version of this
architecture that we've built so far uh
think about this explicitly and then I'm
going to talk about how this connects to
other architectures that already exist
in the world just very briefly so we've
been uh framing this as uh an
architecture for building decentralized
digital twins uh which are local models
of real world systems that run in
network uh and the the role that such
digital Twins play is that they help us
understand the cost and benefits of
strategies and projects that happen in
the real world and we in in our
organization digital Gaia we started out
caring primarily about agroecology so
how do you actually make better
decisions uh meaning better
recommendations negotiations valuations
investments into a farm into a forest
into uh uh bio landscape to make it uh
better to make it more likely to to
survive and
thrive so uh as uh practical
implementation
uh it needs to tackle several real world
challenges first of all uh it needs to
handle distributed non-iid data uh data
is sparse it's heterogeneous it's
private it's potentially
unreliable uh it needs to enable
localized collaborative forecasting and
planning personalized planning and
privacy preserving it needs to uh accept
the fact that it won't be able to
directly control but only recommended
nudge as we disced
test uh and uh the outline of what we
came up with is this concept of the guy
Network which is a mesh of AI agents
called natural entities or ends for
short that act as proxies for Real World
Systems um each end runs on an engine
called fangorn which it uses to inquire
learn plan and allocate resources and
ANS communicate in a language called the
guy
protocol they they use this language to
independ ly interact with their
environments and each other and if we do
this right I I'll show a bit more on
this later but if we do this right the
guy networks Behavior approximates a
single composite agent that handles uh
that interacts with and couples with its
Global in
F cool so um just to give you an
overview of how this works behind under
the hood the fangor engine is really the
heart of our AR architecture and the
core Loop uh that is mentioned here is a
typical active Insurance Loop but uh to
make this work in very heterogeneous and
distributed context there's lots of work
involved so some just some highlights
that I think are going to be
particularly interesting for this crowd
uh first of all so as I said this first
the same core engine needs to be able to
work for very heterogeneous context so
each agent has access to a library of
generative models and these models are
specified using a python based uh prog
probabilistic programming DSL and they
declare what contexts they appropriate
for using a shared ontology uh using
that ontology fangor can then select the
most appropriate model to use online
given the configurations like project
configurations and the kinds of
observational data available so using
the model using model that's appropriate
for uh for a farm or for a forest what
kind of farm what kind of forest what
kind of ecosystem what kind of of um you
know context energy project um and I'm
going to get into the examples right now
because there's more more on the
applications later on so uh we end up
with a network of heterogeneous agents
but that's okay they actually form a a
single model in a formal sense because
they're all connected
hierarchically uh by a system of of
hyperpriors and uh this means that
fangor needs to support inference of
generic hierarchal generative models and
we actually do this automatically using
approximate posteriors with structural
constraints um and so we have this
Global model that connects all the nodes
and describes General facts that apply
over multiple contexts and this means
the whole network needs to jointly
perform inference over this Global model
using a peer-to-peer or Federated
algorithm so initially the way this
works initially uh the network sets the
global posterior to be the same as the
global prior each node then
independently performs local
optimization of the variation of free
energy and then passes the parameters of
the new Global solution to the peers in
the network where they use it as a hyper
prior and this works uh over a broad
range of topologies and under pretty
General constraints and by the way I'd
love to I'd like to mention that uh
there's a lot of overlap and interaction
between the stuff that I'm talking about
here and some of the other presentations
that you're seeing today and I I wasn't
able to reference them explicitly in
this talk but I I'm sure you guys are
going to see the
connections cool so um what it turns out
is that the shared parameters that
represent our Global model are
effectively stored by the network stored
in a Federated parameter store meaning
that each node stores their own local
parameters their private stuff about
their own local context and multiple
nodes store copies of the global
parameters and uh this architecture
because it supports heterogeneous uh
local models it actually allows us to
introduce another kind nodes which we
call ant mot nodes these are nodes that
aggregate scientific and empirical
information using a matter analysis
model and uh we actually uh are able to
use that M analysis model to constraint
our constraint our project level models
or end using quote unquote imported
knowledge that wasn't directly observed
by them which is left to right in this
picture but this actually also goes to
ways so empirical findings from the
projects what actually works on the
ground for this particular project also
informs the end moves posteriors which
is the right to left and so we actually
have a complete uh cycle of of Science
and empirics all implemented using
hierarchical active
entrance so finally uh just uh among the
global parameters that Network learns by
Federated inference are the precisions
associated with data coming from the
different data providers and this gives
each node a way to consume data without
trusted ground truth and basically to
learn together which sources they can
rely on for what uh this is just uh some
of more core features we're working on
integrating many other capabilities into
this architecture not going to go
through all of this uh but basically
what what we're finding is that we have
all the building blocks to turn this
into a full feature decision Network
complete with its own internal knowledge
economy meaning that contributors uh
contributions get attributed and
rewarded in proportion to the to the
free free energy reduction that they
afford cool so uh jumping into
applications uh as I mentioned our main
focus as as an or organization has been
on modeling agroecological projects like
regenerative agriculture and Agro
forestry and this exercise is all the
constraints that we talked about so far
so uh again I'm not going to go into
full detail but to give an overview of
what is the anatomy of a gentic model
for a farm or Forest so started the
right with observables that are things
that we can measure about that ecosystem
about that that local context like the
plant counts and size vegetation indices
from satellite data and so on these are
are linked to latent states which form a
nonlinear dynamical system that's
parameterized by uh the policy the the
the things that modulate the the latent
States um like agricultural
interventions and practices you can
think of the timing of planting at home
harvesting what kinds of crops or trees
get planted what products like
pesticides get applied or not and more
uh as well as covariates so external
events like weather physical risks
Wildfire drought and so on um and so
there's uh some scientific and
measurement parameters uh that that go
into this as well things like uh the
effect sizes of the various actions and
covariants and these local parameters
are conditionally dependent on a set of
global global parameters which as we
discussed they they link information
between different ends and different
sources of
knowledge um uh and uh so these same
Global parameters are used in the M
analysis model and they actually
establish the link between what happened
what is found to happen on the ground
and what is reported in the
literature um and so I'm not going to go
into this because I I think I'm going to
uh run a bit long but basically the
concept is is that we have these project
nodes that correspond to to many farms
and they're each on Independent nodes in
the network they're also connected to
this common meta analysis model and uh
together all of these uh together these
nodes they incorporate uh academic
studies expert knowledge and uh locally
relevant context they do so privately so
only processing the local data locally
and uh through this parameter sharing
they actually jointly uh and iteratively
estimate the the global posterior uh in
a cycle forever for as long as there is
new data uh about the project as long as
there's new studies and new expert
knowledges so so all of this is
happening basically in in an online way
and again the topology can vary but the
principles uh remain the same so just to
to see you show a little bit of how how
uh this works this is just two EPO of
the the the posterior the global
posteriors and this is just location and
scale for for two uh parameters uh the
slope and The Intercept of the
relationship between uh a vegetation
index and the tree biomass in one given
Hector of forest and as you can see this
this converges pretty pretty quickly
it's comparable to to local local only
methods um and just to highlight how
this can be used to to or also the
limits of how this can be used to
estimate uh Source reliability uh here's
a really successful example at the left
it's pretty pretty straightforward to
use this to estimate reliability of of
uh satellite data and for other cases
like very local very uh context specific
data you actually need more data or more
data from more independent sources that
we had in this demo
here um uh
another very useful use case of this is
as we discussed we don't have Direct
Control over what happens at a form we
can only recommend and nudge often we
also like we we get there a node gets
sued up a net gets stood up for an
existing project that has already
happened and we want to find out uh what
actions were taken in the past and the
same uh the same generative model can be
used to
estimate uh what happened in the past
and the example it infers uh when
planting started and when harvests
started for for different
fields um so uh bringing it all together
one of the applications that we've been
using we' working on uh it actually uses
all this Machinery together to validate
claims about projects performance and to
estimate future performance we've
deployed this uh in real world projects
uh this one this the examples here you
see in this photo are by are relevant to
Agro forestry fors in Colombia and uh we
found that this actually helps the
project developers and their funders to
come to a shared understanding of how
successful the project is how much it's
worth in terms of its impact and its
fundability whether it should be scaled
up or or uh needs to change course uh
what is the quality of the strategy
versus other potential strategies for
natural regeneration and so on so uh
it's actually useful on the ground for
decision- making in this context cool so
finally uh I want to talk about the end
State and uh uh going back to our
original motivation of solving
everything I forgive you for thinking
this is nice but hey we're we've been
kind of in this uh down downward spiral
towards the meta crisis for a long time
and what you're telling me doesn't even
come close to solving everything and
you're right uh there's a lot of of
moving pieces that need to be built and
connected but here's the good news um we
can do this uh there's no Mi mystery
here and we don't need per Perfection I
love this quote from Edward F Brook that
says that to define a policy we don't
need it exact empirical measures or
optimality if one jumps from an airplane
it may be nice to have an altimeter but
what one really needs is a parachute so
there is uh only so much that we can get
in terms of dimensioning returns what we
should be really focusing on is uh
creating and refining Solutions
everywhere and connecting them
everywhere um and you might be thinking
about how does this actually scale to
Global goals and how does this actually
get used uh for uh scalably uh building
into the the fabric of decisions in our
in our society uh so about scaling to
Global goals uh I again won't be able to
get into the details but maybe Connor
mentioned this in his presentation
earlier uh we have actually some proof
of Concepts that we can actually build
active agents that that are made of
active active agents so we've shown in
this paper here that a collective of
interacting AC agents uh is able to
perform approximate inference at The
Ensemble level and that this further
that this happens through specific
mechanisms that are mediated by uh by
cognitive cap capabilities like theory
of mind and goal alignment they they
work together to improve Collective
performance by eliminating ambiguity and
through act actively exploiting
diversity um so that's one and the other
question is how do we actually uh build
this kind of stuff into not just these
uh ad hoc decisions but into really the
fabric of decision- making and that that
is our global economic system so uh
talking about here uh work that I did
with Casper HP this is a game that
highlights the ability of ants just like
the ones that we just described to infer
true System state and use it to credibly
incentivize long-term positive outcomes
in an externality heavy scenario uh this
team uh we were able to show that it
works even with adversarial bot
strategies uh and even with high
uncertainty and intentional
misinformation so you can actually get
these ends to to work with uh budgets
and incentives to drive decision- making
that internalized externalities and uh
and compensates for collusion and uh uh
generates long-term positive
outcomes uh that's not all there are
other Solutions uh uh that have been
around for longer than hours uh that
apply similar principles to Global
decision- making problems in the real
world at scale this is one case study
from our partners at cognizant that they
developed for the co co pandemic and
this is not using active inance
formalism this is uh combination of
traditional recurrent neuron networks
for prediction and evolutionary
optimization for prescription and it's
actually able to achieve some pretty
amazing uh stuff it discovers a Paro
front between uh prevention of cases and
uh uh economic cost it's uh it's also a
showcase for hybrid human AI
intelligence they did an initial version
of this model then they launched an X
prise they got a bunch of contributions
for other models and then they did a
meta model uh that discovered a better
burito front and uh even better even
better this tool has actually been used
to advise policy in the real world so
it's actually very exciting that uh
we're working with them and connecting
the dots because we need to connect the
dots we need to bring it all together
this uh this illustration here is just
uh I think a subset of the uh effects of
the of the climate change crisis which
is just one aspect of the meta crisis on
on humans on our society and the economy
and and uh so we actually need to be
able to deploy solutions that work
across many different domains and to
connect these dots uh this means two
things uh the first is interoperability
aligning decisions across context so
that we don't get unintended
consequences and second is reusability
so being able to to transport and
transfer uh learning and structure
across context so for instance using
that evolutionary approach from the from
the co example in in our agricultural
context or in many other possible
context
and this takes a form of libraries of
components apis and so
forth so uh that's what we're working on
so we're launching this Consortium we
just put up the website a few minutes
ago and uh we have the goal of having a
minimal but functionally complete
implementation by the end of next
year uh and this is an open project we
are working on this at our organization
called digital guy but we're also
launching this open Consortium that
welcomes uh contributors from anywhere
both active entrance experts and
non-experts and uh we need a lot of
contributors we need all of you because
this is uh the most important thing that
we could ever be working on together and
we need your help to tackle the many
remaining challenges so if you want to
help us build the planetary grain please
go to guia consortium. org and or reach
out to me you know where to find me uh
and together we can design build and
learn what it takes to achieve planetary
E Generation thank you
W ra thanks for the great
presentation I'll uh post the link to
guy Consortium into the YouTube live
chat but let me get a few quick
questions in so um here we go first uh
question this is
from uh Marco
Lynn
um I agree with the critical importance
of such a project how will you deal with
the challenges of scaling given the
dependence on real world entities like
humans um for dependence on real world
entities like humans for major metac
crisis domains such as geopolitics
social cultural fragmentation and other
particularly hard sense making
domains uh first of all hi Marco yeah
thanks for the question and uh I 100%
agree that uh I'm not claiming that this
is sufficient I'm just claiming that
it's necessary
uh we do have uh a lot of energy that
that a lot of ideas and a lot of energy
that we want to put into exactly what
you described how to uh change the uh
how to weave what we're doing into the
existing incentive Landscapes whether
they're Market incentives or policy
incentives But ultimately this needs to
be uh an enabler just needs to meet
people where they are and we need to be
cognizant that change is not going to
happen overnight at least not right now
right typically these things take a take
a while to mature and then they they
snap into place and we're already
finding some of this happening in some
of the domains that we're working on
where uh nothing happened for a very
long time and then bam hockey stick and
we believe that the same uh can happen
in uh in pretty much anywhere so we're
very
optimistic great what are currently the
greatest challenges for Gaia as an
organization I love that kind of
ambiguous question like is that the guy
Consortium as an organization or is it
guy but let's let's hear both what are
the greatest challenges or frictions for
the Consortium and for the bigger
picture
too Al so uh I I'm gonna I'm not going
to talk about the the technical stuff
for change I'm going to talk about uh
the the more Mana stuff and it's
actually very related to what uh your uh
previous presentation Daniel about that
paper uh about the Institute talked
about and it's really related to to uh
building out this common what we were
calling the common cognitive kernel for
for sense making and decision- making
and uh relatedly uh breaking through
this uh uh this uh culture of sort of
Suspicion and uh surf Wars and
getting uh you know St people St trying
to stake their their claim to something
so we are and always have been uh
extremely open but it's it's kind of
hard anyway to build trust so we
are were aware that it's going to take a
while to build to build this trust with
everybody and uh and I think the only
answer to that is really to be as
participatory and uh and transparent as
possible also uh being humble and uh
knowing where where where we haven't
where we don't have the answer and uh
asking people to to help
us awesome any closing words or
thoughts well if there are no further
questions I uh again I I thank you all
for for paying attention and I'm going
to be reaching out a lot more you're
going to hear a lot more about this
Consortium as I said it was just formed
we just put up a website in time for
this presentation by the way uh thanks
so much to to Mahi and uh and of course
Steve and everybody else who's been a
part of forming and uh and getting this
to getting this ball to start rolling um
we are um you know very early stage very
formative and still uh very pliant so uh
we definitely are we would love I I just
gave you like my perspective on on a
bunch of these things the the the shape
of it that that that has come from from
our work on this so far and even not all
of it just piece that we could cover in
20 minutes or so uh but we are we're
very plural we we want to uh engage with
you
on uh on different paths forward
different opportunities to to to build
things to experiment to connect the dots
to learn together and uh ultimately like
we
we really just want to uh provide a
platform a convening space a protocol uh
uh in the classic sense of the world
word of a you know a shared language a
shared means of communication a shared
means of understanding to find together
what we need to do to to actually build
this third
attractor
awesome call guia
trimtab thank you
exactly thanks so much Daniel and see
you guys soon bye
bye all
right what a cool
presentation